she's very eager to get married my girl
and she can't figure out why I'm not and
this is because marriage is much better
for women like from the beginning
onwards it literally starts with a man
getting on his knees begging you please
spend the rest of your life with ugly
stupid me but is that huh is that enough
no you also get an exquisite piece of
jewelry that costs tens of thousands of
dollars and the arms of a Liberian boy
you know how much you told me you're
supposed to spend on an engagement ring
10 G's but all your [ __ ] crazy
three paychecks that's what she told me
three I'm on a finger it's not even a
good finger you don't use it to write or
eat or [ __ ] you it is useless it I use
this finger is the Simpsons don't have
him none of us noticed
[Applause]
but is that enough no you also get a
party it's not even a party it's a gala
it's straight out of the Great Gatsby
where every all of my friends and family
all of your friends and family gather
around and stare at you the beautiful
blushing bride in a gorgeous gown and
there's some dumb [ __ ] standing
next to her in a rented tux we only have
money to buy the tux because we use the
budget on centerpieces if you don't know
what a centerpiece is guys it's
basically a gorgeous obstruction to keep
you from talking to the other side of
the table it's like a mason-dixon line
but for friendship because we all we
can't make friends we got to be staring
at the bride and then whatever it is
that's walking around to her shoulder
everywhere she goes you replace me with
a fanny pack nobody would notice and I
asked my girl and she's like baby's been
my dream since I was three years old
okay when I was three years old I wanted
a dragon
sometimes your dream is not really you
Lamia is not a great dream there's a
feasible I still dream of being an NBA
how about we read on Madison Square
Garden invite all our friends and family
over and I took on them for eight hours
what about my dreams I'm just saying
there should be something for men you
can honestly I'll let you have the party
that's just for you but something to
balance out the ring I think men should
get engagement cars just a simple look
how unhappy the women are the idea it's
not even equal a diamond is for every a
camera is like is six years it's a whole
different timeline and I don't even like
driving I just want you to feel that
pressure that's all when you're like
babe what kind of car do you want no my
gun depends on how much you love me